[Music]
a dive light is essential when scuba
diving at night
but can also be used for daytime dives
to explore
underwater caves and shipwrecks the
deeper you dive
the more water absorbs certain colors in
the light spectrum
when you use an artificial light you can
see the underwater world in true color
[Music]
the dive light is waterproof to a depth
of 295 feet
it's brighter than a car headlight with
six outer led lights for flood lighting
and three inner leds for alternate spot
lighting the dive light begins as a
conceptual drawing
the mechanical designer sketches out its
basic features
and a few proposed shapes
[Music]
then the company creates foam models
scuba divers test these models
and provide feedback on the comfort of
each shape
this market research results in the
final design
a compact hand mounted dive light with a
user-friendly operating switch
and three led battery life indicators
[Music]
the housing's components are made of
durable plastic pellets
reinforced with glass fiber
workers load the pellets into an
injection molding machine
[Music]
the machine melts them and shoots the
molten plastic into the proper mold for
the component they are making
the machine then cools the plastic to a
solid state
and ejects the newly formed part this is
the reflector
it combines the light from the six outer
leds into a single beam
it's coated in aluminum to increase the
amount of light it reflects
a 3d printer produces prototypes for all
of the parts before they are
manufactured
guided by a computer the printer shoots
out plastic
to build the part in three dimensions
from the bottom up
once the prototype is approved they make
a mold for mass production
[Music]
this part is called the light pipe it
has oval covers for the three led
battery life indicators
and a waterproof seal
[Music]
once all the housing parts are molded
assembly can begin
they insert the light pipe into the main
body of the housing
then they attach a switch which turns
the light on and off
it also toggles the light between
spotlight and floodlight modes
[Music]
they don't need to pierce the housing to
connect the switch
the switch slides a magnet over the
outside of the housing
the magnetic field communicates through
the housing to sensors inside
next they insert and connect the circuit
board
[Music]
then the lithium-ion rechargeable
battery
they plug its connector into the circuit
board
this cover holds the internal parts in
correct alignment
a silicone o-ring forms a water-tight
seal between the main body and the light
head
they snap the reflector over the nine
leds which are attached to a round
circuit board
the circuit board is metal so that it
will absorb the heat the led lights
generate
the screw-on aluminum bezel makes
contact with the circuit board
transferring the heat out of the housing
and into the water
they conduct the first quality control
test in water
the dive light is turned on to verify
that it will run for 65 minutes on a
full
charge
[Music]
in the second quality control test they
submerge the dive light in a pressurized
tank
this simulates the pressure the light
would be subjected to at an underwater
depth of about 300 feet
[Music]
that's over twice the diving depth of a
typical recreational dive
if the light doesn't spring a leak it
passes the test
they fully recharge the battery which
takes two and a half hours
at full charge all three indicators
light up green
as the charge drains the indicators
change from green
to orange to red then to flashing red
so scuba divers are never in the dark
about how much
juice is left in their light
you